hi and welcome to episode number 41 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Franciscan porn and I'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark hey
Francesca are you doing today doing
great knowing that I bid you yesterday
at ping pong and I beat you twice so
there you go whatever let's forget about
so I'm very happy today because we have
we're gonna be talking with team Kelton
from the cat labs yeah desk artists labs
depending on how good your friend Jesus
yeah not and he's going to be telling us
about how they use google cloud to do
maps yeah he is it's a really
interesting story around particularly
preemptive all VMS actually yeah /
interval VMS and really really really
big data sets really big game sets yeah
very excited about that I really enjoyed
talking to him so I hope that you will
also enjoy the interview and then at the
end we will will have a question of the
week yeah we're gonna talk a little bit
about what you can get for free yeah
which is always good free stuff is good
so concretely what are the products or
features or API is that you can use for
free app to a given point so what
products have free tears and Google
cloud platform we're going to be
discussing them a little bit not giving
all of them because there's too many
products but to give you an idea what
you can do for free basically yep but
before that we have the cool thing of
the week and as usual it is the cool
things of the week I think we should
just rename the sec yeah we should
rename it of the week yeah so the first
one that the two first ones are actually
related to the podcast isn't made a cool
thing of the week yeah the first one is
we got transcripts yeah which is really
cool so now we get we get automated
transcripts coming through there will be
at least 15 out because that's how many
I have right now on the website
available but will be gradually
increasing that to increase increase all
of them so yeah if you want to see the
text or read the actual podcast it's
pretty cool we can do that and the other
thing is the thing you built as well
yeah so I've been working on it for like
a couple days and it involves ffmpeg and
darker and
lots of pain but now we will be reusing
every single episode from the Google
cloud platform podcast to youtube so
that's a pretty cool i already posted
three of them but they're still not
public but by the time this episode
comes out and probably everything will
be out so go check it out we'll have a
link to the to the playlist from the
show notes yeah I think this is actually
kind of cool because if you if you
subscribe to youtube videos you can do
that anyway so it gives you another
avenue to subscribe to the podcast but
if you're a YouTube red or google play
music person who owns a solution to that
means you can download them for offline
use 20 so you can actually listen to it
much like you would a regular forecast
nice yeah the other thing about that
that is cool and yeah I'm actually very
excited also by the transcripts because
I got an email long time ago at the
beginning of the podcast from someone
saying that they had problems
understanding English and they good
rather have the random version of it yep
cool perfect we have a loan perfect and
then we have a non-medical thing of the
week an actual cool thing of the week
which is gr pc hit the version 120 yeah
this is really cool i'm a huge huge fan
of GOP see which is a remote procedure
remote procedure call framework that
came out of google that's open source
that yeah it's been kind of under
development for a while but has now hit
one point 0 which means there's a lot
more they've improved the performance of
it installing all the tools is now a lot
easier my favorite thing actually is
they've released a performance dashboard
that's available you can go look there
and see like what sort of throughput you
can expect to get with different
language comparisons can see our PC
supports about 10 different languages so
glad that is nice yeah I also saw that
there's a bunch of people using it from
open source projects I get city or
container d and cockroaches to be but
also companies so like I think that the
biggest one that is using it is Netflix
and Google we actually have AP is that
only work with grp see already like big
table yep and then there's other AP eyes
that have both rest and grp see api's so
yeah check it out we'll have links to
the to the announcement from the show
notes
absolutely cool well that sounds all
really awesome why don't we go talked to
Tim yeah let's go through that sounds
good it's my distinct pleasure to
announce that we are joined today by
gentleman by the name of Tim Kelton from
des cartes labs are you doing today Tim
I'm doing really good excellent thank
you so much for joining us today I'm
pretty excited to be talking to you i
think the stuff you do in the company
you work forward to some really
interesting stuff but tell us a little
about you and who you are and what you
do and all that kind of stuff sure i'm
an engineer and part of the founding
team here at Dakara and my main focus is
cloud architecture and then building and
scaling what we call our cloud
supercomputer which is basically a
forecasting platform and so I end up
using a range of Google cloud platform
tools to accomplish this goal and that's
mainly to see how the earth is changing
every single day and before Descartes I
was a research and development engineer
for 15 years at Los Alamos National
Laboratory and there I worked on a wide
range of projects pose focused around
deep learn the most recent project that
lasted about six years was focused
around deep learning and applying deep
learning to real-world problem areas
like satellite imagery and then a
portion of that team left Los Alamos to
start take heart cool so you mentioned
that the CAF the lab it allows you to
see how the earth changes what what does
that mean yes so we're building a living
atlas of the world and how we're doing
that is we're applying machine learning
with massive scale data sets such as
satellite imagery also datasets like
global weather pricing ground truth even
customer data and then we feed that into
our forecasting platform and then we can
build our machine lot excuse excuse me
machine learning models
and constantly try and improve those
models and this allows us to not just
see what's happened historically but
also it lets us forecast into the future
kind of interestingly enough we mainly
are focused on areas that humans just
could never scale to do things like
global scale food production you just
couldn't get enough people on the ground
counting how productive a field is all
over the world it just isn't scalable so
we're using satellite data in that way
and it's it's really exciting we're only
20 months old so it's a really early
stage company but we're moving really
quickly so exactly how much data are you
talking about you talking about like
satellite imagery and focus whether I
mean like how big is these data sets yes
so the data sets very right now we
currently have compressed around three
and a half petabytes of data they were
storing in google cloud platform only
only a couple of petabytes it's fine
yeah and that that process is like
that's over a number of years like is
that like recently like what's that sort
of time series as well yeah that's an
interesting area you know as most people
that do machine learning or use tools
like cafe or tensorflow can tell you a
really big challenge with machine
learning tools is having an accurate set
of data to train the models and then
improve the models accuracy and when
you're doing things like looking at the
earth having a really large time window
of data helps helps out a lot and often
with satellite data training sets can be
extremely varied and things like weather
cycles are not just repeatable year
after year they vary quite a bit through
time so the longest continuous
observations of the earth came from
NASA's Landsat constellation and that
was a launched in 1973 and that's
actually available on thanks to their
Google Earth engine team on Google Cloud
and so our first kind of big project
really early on in the company was we we
basically saw we needed a lot of back
test data to be able to test models
through throughout time and we basically
process 43 years of this NASA Landsat
imagery so in pixel terms that's going
to be 2.8 petter pixels of data in data
terms that's about a petabyte of data
and so we did all of that on Google
compute engine and that was about just a
little under 16 hours and that's using
30,000 virtual CPU cores and that was
all on preempt able VMs so it was quite
sizeable and I should say that you know
most as impressive as as Google compute
engine scaling up probably the most
interesting part to us was gc's network
and how well the network actually scaled
we were actually seeing for most of that
16 hours over 20 gigabytes a second
going into google compute engine and
then over 8 gigs in parallel going out
of google compute engine and you know
we've worked in places most of us come
from Los Alamos or have worked on other
large-scale super computing clusters and
those types of numbers are on par with
anything you would see in a
high-performance super computer system
today so we basically are using google
to build the same types of systems that
we used to we were used to working with
and google recently actually had a paper
about their networking called I think
it's Meg live and so that was really
fascinating as an end user we saw how it
scaled and that was really interesting
but then reading the paper of how how
all those components were built together
was was pretty fascinating so you were
processing that entire pedophile during
that time yeah we're running that all
through our processing pipeline how much
sure roundabouts is like sort of that
cost I mean you talked a little bit
about pre-emptive VMs there but so
pre-emptive all is dramatically reduce
your costs if your workload doesn't need
to last over 24 hours so for our for
this use case our whole goal was to get
it done in under
day and they were great for that in when
we ran this in early 2015 the cost for
just compute was just under ten thousand
dollars but then I recently just looked
at the there was recent pricing drops in
compute engine and so those prices now
would be about thirty six hundred
dollars so that kind of shows the
difference in pricing that's not the
data storage the data storage is a
little more than than that we go through
a petabyte that's that's you know not
not too shabby that's not that is pretty
amazing actually so you mentioned real
quick about preventable VMs printable
pre pre free what did I say you see
preventable preventable not preempt evil
vm sorry why did you choose them what is
the the big thing I understand that it
is it is more affordable than the normal
VMs but what kind of restrictions and
what kind of design decisions did you
take into account yes so pre-emptive
balls at maximum will only last you for
24 hours and so you need a process to be
processing some sort of processing tasks
that's going to obviously last less than
that so you're not going to run a
production web server database server on
that but for really large processing
work loads such as machine learning
model training having a lot of like pre
processing pipelines there they're a
great use case for that for us we use
asynchronous task queues to load data or
the processing we're going to do in to
the task queue and then connect up all
these pre-emptive all instances via
instance groups and then you can scale
up and down the instance groups and now
you can scale up and down the instance
groups across different inside of his
own different regions so that that's
quite useful cool so you are able to
sort of leverage the power of printable
VMs to basically reduce your costs more
than anything else yeah it's a huge cost
cost reduction compared to the big you
know just running a regular vm for a few
hours
so we use them quite heavily and all of
our processing pipelines now as a cost
reduction but also you know with machine
learning a lot of times you're training
and Retraining a model to try and
improve your accuracy so we have a lot
of like kind of really large-scale bulk
workloads and we've kind of taken the
road of not going down the path of using
something like Hadoop or things because
we have a lot of C and C++ and Python
code and so instead we use basically use
Google Cloud storage as our large
distributed file system and we know that
will scale way beyond our current needs
and it has really really fast network
access from compute engine so we can
connect real quickly and so it has a lot
of benefits to over over trying to get C
or C++ or Python code to work inside of
something like Hadoop so but the issue
obviously automated obviously but the
issue with pre-emptive all VMS is they
could shut down how do you deal with
that happening do you there's like a
retry making nezam you use or how do you
deal with that yeah we use some pretty
basic open-source task queues we use a
python q called celery and that has a
back-end persistence store you can
configure a bunch of different ones we
use Redis we're pretty big fans of
lettuce and so we write all the tasks
into the queue and then basically if if
they still are not done and within a
certain time you can retry the tasks or
rerun certain tasks over again and make
sure you processed all of your work or
our workloads are in many situations
they're kind of fall into this
embarrassingly parallel problem so do
you you mentioned that you were using a
synchronous tasks could you talk a
little bit more about that what is are
using pops up by using task queues what
kind of public are using oh yeah we use
so we just use an open source library
it's called celery it's a Python library
and that has configurable backends and
on that back-end we use Redis in memory
and that's all just running on a regular
that's on an on
to pull instance so because we do not
want that to go away and then for
monitoring we use the stack the Redis
stackdriver agent and that keeps track
of how many concurrent connections and
how much load for various threads on the
Redis cluster cluster that's running
there that's kind of a great way to see
if there's a son of spike or change when
that's kind of your central hub that all
your work runs around you need that to
really be up and be reliable cool so we
talked a bit about obviously that
initial data set I'm guessing you have
ongoing data that's coming in now is
your company's expanded you have more
and more information coming in on an
ongoing basis with that be right correct
work processing data probably right now
so we're talking we're basically
constantly ingesting new data in our
processing pipelines literally from
hundreds of different satellites not
just those eight NASA Landsat satellites
right now we're at about three and a
half petabytes of compressed data and
that's including that's a lot of thats
public satellite imagery that's open you
know NASA European Space Agency various
people like that but then we also have
private partners as well and so we're
constantly as we get new updates to
various geographic regions or we're
working on a new problem case may be
inside of agriculture or studying a new
crop that's in a different part of the
world will look at different sets of
imagery that we might not always hit
every single day we have about 25
terabytes a day that just constantly
flows in and that varies from day to day
but in the future we're expecting this
to basically be over 30 petabytes in the
next year and a half and that's kind of
a cool thing in space right now or in
space and technology most of your
listeners probably watch youtube videos
of SpaceX and SpaceX landing rockets on
a floating barge in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean is pretty awesome but from
a cost perspective a big part of your
cost to getting satellites up into orbit
is
actually the rocket launches and making
them reusable and that the other side of
that you have smaller and smaller
satellites and so they're made with more
and more commodity parts they're often
called cube SATs or an example of that
would be a Silicon Valley startup called
planet or like Google has a team called
Terra Bella and they have a what they
call a small set so you have that on the
other end so we're going to get more and
more sensors in the next few years going
up into space seeing the earth every
single day and teams like ours will be
able to look at how the earth is
changing every single day instead of you
know people manually downloading an
image and trying to compare 1121 so
going back to your your stack what is
the thing that is running on your
virtual on your pre interval machines do
you have are you running guess Python
directly they're using containers what
kind of job do you run we use both both
raw code would we use startup scripts in
the GCE instances and we use containers
on some of the more involved
configurations that we want to make
maintain consistency and make sure a
running tested version of the code is
operating in a way we're expecting we'll
use like startup scripts with instance
groups so they could either connect to
Google container registry and pull the
container down because that's really
really quick access to pull that
container because it's just sitting in
Google Cloud storage in inside of our
project or if we run a startup script
then you're kind of just defining
scripts to run and install but most of
our workload is is Python or C or C
wrapped in Python scythe on for most
most of our workloads and I think that's
pretty pythons a pretty popular language
in machine learning world these days
cool um so I'm actually really curious
you've probably looked at more satellite
data than I don't know maybe a lot of
people I'm kind of curious to know like
what are the most interesting things
you've managed to find out about you
know the planet or like society as a
whole like what have you seen in those
imagery that's kind of been really
interesting
yeah that's a tough you see all types of
random things a the funniest maybe not
funny is very obvious after a while you
don't realize how cloudy the earth
actually is in many times of the day
often when you're trying to find an
image you know if there's like a big
sporting event or something like that
and you have a cloud actually blocking
so we actually have a technique for
being able to process and fuse together
many different scenes to you know remove
the clouds over time but yeah I don't
I'm trying to think of something really
really bizarre I've seen one of our
co-founders he actually located the spot
that the end the time when the original
start the original Star Wars movie where
it was actually filmed he went all the
way back and found this that because we
had this massive archive basically since
1973 and so he found all the exact
images from that location that's pretty
cool i guess i'm more more day to day i
know you do a letter around like fruit
yields as well i think is that right
correct that's our first main products
are actually focused a little bit more
in agriculture in basically modeling the
global food supply we look down on the
earth and we can see various fields all
across a growing region not just a small
County but we could see a whole state or
a whole country or even the whole globe
and we can see that every single day so
organizations like the US Department of
Agriculture will manually send out
surveys to farmers and they'll get a you
know a small statistical sampling of the
population how the food production is
growing but we basically are seeing
every field all across the globe every
single day and taking a measurement of
the actual health of the fields and so
that allows us to not just classified
the fields and what they are if it's a
cornfield or soybean field or wheat
field but also to be able to look at how
much is that field going to produce and
what's our estimate and that leads us
into
what we have is more of a forecasting
product that is that is actually very
interesting do you use any kind of
forecasting to be able to predict things
like well given the kind of fields you
have and given the the weather forecast
that we have there's going to be a lack
of food in some country in a couple
months something that is that something
that you you've ever used I don't think
we're going quite that far down the
analysis like is there going to be
famine outbreak in country X or Y it's
it's definitely something it could be
possible right now we're looking at
overall yields there's obviously a lot
of you know how much production of corn
might there be in in a given in the
United States and this growing season
are in South America during this growing
season but longer-term works hoping to
expand to more and more crops and more
more geographic regions basically and we
also actually have a new mobile app that
we built we're using that we actually
built it on firebase we have an iOS and
Android app and anyone can actually pull
that down and see our delayed forecast
it's not in real time it's a week behind
and they can actually use that to look
up that location and see what we're
predicting to be the yield of corn say
for that given County in Iowa or some
place like that and you can even vote
and you can say well we actually think
you're totally wrong or yes that seems
about right and you can kind of provide
feedback there cool all right that was
really great before we wrap up here is
there anything else you want to mention
maybe something we've missed or
something you want to kind of mention or
plug uh that's that's the main things
moving forward we're hoping we're really
excited about some of the new changes on
on Cooper Nettie's and being able to
actually run jobs and then having auto
scaling on jobs so we are hoping that
more and more of like our daily
processing pipeline will be able to work
that way so that that's pretty exciting
and then we should be having more and
more updates obviously with our mobile
app and our website so if you're excited
about corn yields or soybean yield so
you'll be able to key in on that not
sure what we're predicting in the Bay
Area i'm guessing it's pretty minimal
right now but yeah will constantly have
new updates and will always be improving
our models and working to try and make
them more and more accurate and use that
large set of data to improve the
accuracy in our forecast excellent great
well thank you so much for taking the
time to talk to us and tell us about so
many cool predictions really that was
really really interesting well thanks
guys I enjoyed it vente getting for such
an amazing interview and learned a lot
about how you can manage such huge
amount of data with printable VMS yeah
it was super super cool and just like
the large amount of storage in the
amount of data that they have moving
around their system at any given point
in time is pretty incredible yeah it is
pretty amazing we'll have links actually
we'll have images in the show notes that
so you can have an idea of the kind of
maps they generate see if you're curious
about it but now it's time to go with a
question of the week and the question of
the week it i know i'm not sure where it
comes from but i know that i had it in
the last GDG in san francisco which is
about google cloud platform one of our
co-workers Terry gave a talk and at the
end someone ass okay so what are the
things I can do for free on Google cloud
platform and the first part of the
question is well when you sign up for
the for Google cloud platform you get
already three hundred dollars that are
valid for two months there are 60 days
yeah 60 days so so with that you can do
many things like three hundred dollars
is a decent amount of money you can run
many instances for quite a while yeah I
didn't really say people will probably
run out of the 60 days before they run
into the three hundred dollars generally
speaking generally speaking yeah unless
you go and you start like a 32 cores
instant anything like that this is a
little bit more but otherwise yeah you
should be fine with that but even
without signing up and actually going
through the free to the free trial
there's
also there's also some products that
allow you to have a free tier that is
there forever not limit of time so you
can just be there and use it for free
and I actually do it all the time one of
them is app engine which is one of my
favorite ones there is so the free tier
is 28 3 instance hours per day so
slightly you can get like one point I'm
gonna do the math slightly more than
that then we all know III don't do
things in my head hi um yes it slightly
more than a day for a front innocence uh
yeah and available to be used and the
good thing is that most of the time
you're actually gonna use way less than
that because if you don't have that much
traffic the instances will shut down
automatically so in general that is way
more than enough to your personal
projects and stuff like that so so that
is pretty awesome and once you have that
it's like oh so do I have access to any
other free things I need to store data
well you can use the datastore for free
and there's a I think it is the first
gigabyte right yeah there's a first
gigabyte of storage is free and then you
can do up to fifty thousand reads 20,000
rights and 20,000 deletes and that is
per day so 50 thousand reads per day it
is this a sign on traffic so you can
check it out also you get some other
things like mail and you're a fetch and
task queues there's also different
different levels of free tier for those
yeah and it's worth noting now with data
store like it's not just tied to App
Engine anymore so if you're using data
store outside of App Engine you still
sit into that at three tiers well yeah
you can totally use the rest api and get
that free that free tier also what else
so there's also bigquery one of our most
favorite big data processing tools that
gives you the first terabyte of data
process per month to be free nice which
is really cool especially if you're
playing with any of our public data sets
and you want to have a go with some of
those to see what's possible you can do
a fair bit of processing without don't
worry about paying for it and even if
you don't want to use the
public data sets you can also upload
yours you don't pay for uploading data
you pay for how much data you are
actually storing but it's only two cents
per gigabyte per month so you can you
can get started quite easily for not
very much especially taking into account
that you get those three hundred dollars
for free $300 / 02 02 is a lot yeah yeah
yeah don't let's go in a lot let's give
it a lot then what else a vision a TI ya
the vision API vision API it is really
cool I it's one of my favorite api's
because it allows you to the things that
like they basically seem like magic it's
magic yes basically magic and everything
you need to know is how to use Jason so
it's pretty amazing yeah and it's really
cool so it doesn't necessarily work her
image it works her feature so you're
like asking an image say can we label
detection or OCR this text so you could
do multiple features / image but the
first a thousand units per month is free
feature so that's that you can you can
get a decent amount of stuff done there
yeah I could say that it is not a huge
amount so if you have an application
that is actually used you will hit that
limit quite quick but this is perfect
for development you're doing development
and testing this is totally fine and you
will probably not hit it anytime soon so
that that is really cool then we have a
bunch of all the things that they're not
really free but they're cheap enough
like they round down to zero and yeah
like one of my one of the examples is
pops up pops up is 200 million
operations it is 40 cents so basically 1
billion operations is about one coffee I
like that we should we should do that
for what the cuff like / coffee that
actually really pens if you're drinking
coffee in San Francisco it is like half
a coffee yeah yeah so yeah there's a
bunch of them there they're really
really really affordable so we have a
link will have actually a table with a
bunch of different free tears and links
to all the pricing pages and everything
from the show notes so if you're
interested in this go check it out but
the most important thing to take into
account
basically if you want to get started use
the free trial and you can always get
the App Engine plus datastore which
scale automatically for free up to a
decent amount of traffic awesome well I
think that brings us to the end of yet
another episode are you heading off
anywhere just for fun kappa sodes
what're you up to i'm going to edit
Jasper funk episode and he should come
up soon also I am working on open
sourcing the the little tool that i
wrote to push podcast episodes to
youtube nice that's gonna be fun yeah
awesome when this comes out i will
literally be at pax dev I'm going to be
attending packs dev in Seattle Seattle
yeah so that'll be good and then in
September i will be at one of my
favorite conferences i will be a strange
loop doing a couple of little things
they will see what we'll see what
happens i need to coordinate with some
people but i love that conference it's
loads of fun sounds fun maybe next year
I'll attend may yes yeah well thanks so
much again for taking the time to record
a new episode with me thank you very
much and thank you very much to all our
listeners for tuning in once again yeah
talk to y'all next week see you next
week
you